[music]
>> How many people know all 114 very well?
Raise your hand.
Very well. One.
Two.
Two. No, very well.
Very well.
Name the meanings.
Chapter number 50.
Tell us. You don't know very well. So,
don't raise your hand unless you are,
yeah? Now, negative remarks.
Brother from Nigeria said he knew very
well.
See, today in the schedule
all was supposed to be prepared with the
homework given 2 weeks before. Correct?
And one of the homework was
Surah's names with meanings. So,
actually when I ask who is well
prepared, all 90 should raise their
hands.
Only three raised.
First person only knocked out. Surah 80
is which one?
Inshallah, we'll take the test.
Three people raised. One I checked, one
failed, but very well. The time doesn't
permit. If I start checking then I'll
lose the time of the break. Inshallah,
but good. You should have been prepared
with all 114.
But to make things easier, what we do,
we ask you to prepare for 14 days.
Actually, previously it was 1 month time
we give.
And first day we don't take up only.
What then we'll do? Every day we'll only
check first 25 Surahs.
So, those who have not even done the
homework well,
at least do your homework from today.
So, today we are not even taking up your
3 minutes prepared speech. We'll take it
tomorrow.
Correct?
Previously it wasn't like that.
You gave you have to be now we are
making things easy for you. So that you
get relaxed. Some people may find the
situation different. The city of Bombay
may be hot
or maybe polluted.
So we want to keep everyone relaxed.
So we will spread it out
to see to it that even those people who
were not able to do the homework
in the next couple of weeks mashallah
they will be well versed with
everything. Unless you're not well
versed.
Inshallah you not leave Bombay.
Unless you run away.
And the second question was what is
surprise?
Surprise in English means surprise.
Surprise means something you don't
expect.
So if you're asking me brother Zakir can
I come to know what question will be
asked in the test paper? The test paper
you can't ask. Correct?
So that's the surprise.
So inshallah when the surprise comes
you will understand what is a surprise.
Inshallah.
Any other questions?
We'll have a tea break. We are running
short.
I think we are behind schedule by about
half an hour.
40 minutes we are behind schedule.
Inshallah we'll have a tea break for
half an hour inshallah and we'll resume
inshallah
sharp at 11:35 inshallah. 11:35 we'll
resume. So see to it that where you had
your
dinner yesterday.
The same place have your tea and come
back within half an hour inshallah. Wa
akhiro da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil
alamin.
Alhamdulillah.
Welcome all of you
with the Islamic greeting
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
I hope you had a good tea break.
Now, we have the next session.
That is the introduction of the
participants.
And I request that each one of you
should introduce yourself
the way you'd like to introduce. And you
have been given a time limit of 4
minutes.
Neither speak short, neither long.
See to that your introduction is
exactly 4 minutes.
It can differ by half a minute plus or
minus. That's it.
And we'd also like to see how well you
time yourself.
Even this will be noted. If we say 4
minutes, how do you time yourself?
Correct? So, inshallah, I'll be sitting
down in the audience.
I request the participants
to come by themselves
from the left side,
give the
introduction,
and they can go back to your
stage from here itself. Then the next
participant, inshallah, brother Shafiq,
then brother Ibrahim,
then Farik,
and so on and so forth.
And again, going that side, going back.
So, all the 19 participants, I would
like you to handle yourself, come on the
stage,
give your introduction, your name, your
background, whatever you want to speak.
How you want to introduce yourself,
you want to mention your qualification,
you want to tell you from where you're
coming. But naturally, since people are
coming from different parts of the
world, I request
that besides telling your name, also say
from which city you're coming, which
organization you belong to, regarding
your qualification, regarding your
passion for Dawah, how did you come, and
all these. Wrap it up in about 4
minutes, so that
all of us will be introduced to each
other
in 4 minutes' time. Inshallah. So, all
are ready?
So, inshallah, we'll finish the session,
and after the session, we'll have the
break, because we're running short by
about 45 minutes. We want to catch up.
After this session, we'll have the Zuhr
salah, the break, and then we'll
continue with the balance session,
insha'Allah.
So, I request
the first person to come on the stage,
insha'Allah.
Firstly, my name
I am from
Adamawa state,
Nigeria.
Northeast Nigeria.
From Africa, also.
I am 27 years old.
And currently, I am studying
information technology
in the Institute
of Medical Science, known as Nims
University, Jaipur, here in Rajasthan,
India.
I'm in 200 level, that's year two.
I am the fifth born of my father. I'm
the fifth born.
We are 11 in number.
So, alhamdulillah,
I studied also Quran, alhamdulillah,
masha'Allah.
And
I I I'm also
doing part-job work in my country,
which they sponsor me to study here in
India.
And
my inspiration about da'wah is that
alhamdulillah, my father
is a da'ee
with a known organization in Nigeria,
Jama'atu Izalatil Bid'ah Wa Iqamatis
Sunnah.
So, I started having such a
motivation from him.
He used to take me along whenever he is
going for dawa
before
he died.
So, I have this right from the
right from my childhood.
So, one of my mission is that
one of my biggest and
my intention of coming to India
is that
to be to visit IRF Foundation. And
alhamdulillah, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in his mercy
has accepted my prayers.
Today, I am here standing here
because
I consider
Dr. Zakir Naik
as my mentor.
So, alhamdulillah for this opportunity.
I thank Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for
this
mercy upon me.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
Specifically for Dr. Zakir Naik or Zakir
Bhai.
Uh I'm Ahmad Shafiq Ahmad Shafiq bin
Muhammad Apandi. Uh I normally introduce
myself as Shafiq Apandi.
Because Ahmad Shafiq bin Muhammad Apandi
in the international world like going to
India, China, Taiwan to introduce
yourself with such a long name is
quite an alarming for many people. So, I
normally introduce myself as Shafiq
Apandi.
I'm from Malaysia. I'm from the East
Coast of Malaysia, Kelantan.
I've been moving around since I've since
I was born cuz my father is a soldier.
So, I never stayed in one state within
Malaysia more than three or maximum four
years. So, I have been traveling from
one state to another states in Malaysia
within Malaysia.
Being being like that, I've been able to
to speak all the dialects in the Malay
dialects at least in Malaysia. So, that
was my background and then before coming
here, I did my undergrad in
biotechnology. So, I wasn't coming from
a religious background or like
Islamically educate education background
per se.
So, from my high school to in
university, I've been
uh my background is science background.
So, my passion for da'wah started when I
was in university life. I I joined lots
of activities.
Uh specifically to the auto non-Muslim
is the NGO called Hidayah Center from
Kelantan and also IOA Islamic Outreach
Abim Center through the program called
Masjid Tour Guide. So, that was uh how I
I started becoming active like because
we have a lots of masjid in Malaysia and
we use masjid as a platform to do da'wah
and then alhamdulillah like Masjid Putra
Jaya in Malaysia, we have
at least I have to speak like
on a monthly basis to 1,000 4,000
non-Muslims every month.
Just personally, that's was how and
alhamdulillah now I'm I've been
traveling around. Uh I've been learning
languages for the motivation of learning
languages also coming from
being involved in da'wah through masjid
because I have to speak multiple
languages. Almost every day I have to
switch languages. At night, people from
from different countries French and at
night I have to study some French and
then have to translate some
da'wah materials in French and then the
other the next day Chinese came and then
we have to learn Chinese and then So,
that motivate me to focus learning
languages different languages and
personally I I've chosen Mandarin as my
uh
uh fifth language to to learn and so I
traveled to China and then I I just got
back from Taiwan before I got the
opportunity the call from IRF
to
involve with this big project.
Alhamdulillah and it has always been my
dream to meet Dr. Zakir Naik in person.
Allah Mashallah I I've I've
I'm really I'm 25 years old. Uh I'm very
young uh probably in in relation to most
of the participants here. I have no
background in speaking in large
audience.
I hope that you will continue giving me
chance and train me
and
make me
the best like effective die inshallah.
>> [music]
[music]